i uh i find writing really really hard
and really painful
and um but i'd like to say just honestly
from the bottom of my heart that the
reason that i do it
is this so
uh so it's made it all really worth it
guys
i don't know i think you just have to
keep trying to
stay as present as possible and write as
presently as possible
rather than try and second-guess an
audience or try and please people just
constantly try and move people rather
than impress people
basically trying to disarm an audience
as much as you can with comedy and then
um really punch them in the gut with a
drama as
uh when they least expect it if people
are laughing they're kind of giving you
their heart a bit so
they're sort of asking you to break it
in some way i think she comes out into
the world fighting she wants to be funny
she wants to entertain you she wants you
to have a good time
but also she desperately wants to
connect and i feel like
we can all relate to that to a certain
degree but she's still outrageous and
horny
and busy and tired like the rest of us
[Applause]
i was trying to straddle the two genres
at once so i wanted to present as a
comedy and then twist
into a drama when you laugh you're
really really vulnerable and
what she does with her writing is she
gets you just when you're laughing and
it comes out of nowhere
people open themselves up to then be
punched in the heart
the deeper she digs the more gold she
finds and
you know things get just joyous there
are joyous things
lifted out of that basically trying to
disarm an audience as much as you can
with comedy
and then um really punch him in the gut
with a drama
as uh when they least expect it and i
think an audience makes himself so
vulnerable and open to you when when
they're laughing when they
allow you to make them laugh that um
that's when they trust you foolishly
your creative partner vicki jones has
said that in terms of your writing
process
you want to make your scripts phoebe
proof because you have a tendency to
as a writer always see one step ahead of
what's coming so you kind of
intentionally it's
it's a conscious decision to do the
unexpected is what you mean
yeah completely i mean and it was it's
you know and i think probably a lot of
actors have this but i can predict
things very quickly in movies you used
to drive vicky insane because i'd be
like she'll be able to speak french
and or i'd be like like she's going to
end up with him or like that building's
going to burn down and i could just feel
the structure of things
and um and so much of the work we did um
when we were we had a theater company
and we were producing new writing nights
so much of it was you know each new
writing night we'd give
a brief to the writers which were to
challenge one thing in the audience like
make an audience fall in love with the
character make an audience
forgive a character of a heinous crime
or like find something that makes an
audience laugh and then makes an
audience feel sick for laughing
and we used to do these monthly and i
learned so much there about how to
surprise your audience because
as an audience myself i just i only ever
want to be surprised in a truthful way
not a kind of like
but i want to i want to be surprised as
much as
people surprise me you know people
surprise each other all the time
and i think with claire you know she's
the one i have most fun with really the
sister character because
the more you think oh this is where
claire would be sort of classically anal
about something
and it would be in those moments and i'd
be like but that's where you switch it
and that's when she's actually quite
cool about something or she finds
something funny
and i think that's where you you key
into loving a character when you think
you know them and then actually they
they're deeper or weirder or you know or
cleverer than you thought originally
hello um so i was wondering it's my
question's in terms of structure
um and i know you said you had quite a
lot of guidance from lydia when you got
to from stage two uh structuring it for
tv
but um i just wondered how you tackled
that
difference and obviously you're writing
the play and then that's got a certain
structure to it you transfer that to tv
um and the reason i'm asking is because
i write scenes and i think oh that's a
lovely scene
and then i can't put that anywhere or
structure into
i mean with the risk of the answer being
just be phoebe walnut bridge
if you want to write an international
hit comedy i just
wanted i'm trying um
what how you tackled that kind of
difference
um god i was in exactly the same
position you were in scenes
jokes i have ideas but they're just
fitting them together i think if you
have enough
that you can write them on posts and
write them on your wall and just put
them together because i think
i've never thought structure first i've
always thought material first
and i think you're the same with evicts
and and that's how we operated so much
material first jokes first character
first
and we just put them all on the wall um
and then honestly just the game of what
if you put this next to this
and usually the more unusual that
pairing is of those scenes or those
scenes you put in an episode the more
interesting
it it comes with it's something
something happens when you put two
things that should be together
and then you start pulling a story out
of that this is probably really bad
advice because anyone's supposed to
structure first and then you said
send it to your commissioners and go
this is the structure of the episode
and just send like a screwed up post-it
note going out
but um but that that really really
helped was that it was just
just knowing that you're as long as
you're enjoying writing those scenes
then then once you've got enough then
start playing with it
i think the hook thing at the end that
was really helpful
at the beginning yes knowing the end
really really helps yeah um
and then you know you should just go far
away from the end
emotionally as you possibly can that's
my instinct anyway and
i think knowing how you and we were
doing our dry right stuff theater stuff
um early on a lot of our experiments
were how do you want to make the
audience feel
like what is the journey emotional
journey you want them to go on and that
really helps me rather than thinking
like
starting off thinking like this would
work a story b story c story
it's at this point if you found a moment
a scene that you know
works and it's going to make them feel
that you need to hit them with it
as a surprise so then work away from
that and
it's very instinctual sorry was that at
all helpful
sorry how much do you
uh personally relate and i ask that
because i think when a show like this
comes out that feels confessional
and for some reason within our culture
and i think maybe it's just in the
united states
when a woman does a show that is
confessional there tends to be this sort
of rallying around it as if that's that
person and
this is sort of their confession so ask
how much do you actually sort of relate
to this character in the sense of
presenting humor over grief or
having like a a shield of dark dark
humor rather than sort of
exposing your feelings i'm com
completely and holy
i feel
deeply really deeply to this character
she's very personal to me and
um um i mean i mean
some of the jokes and all good
situations have been lifted from my life
but i think
the the tone and the humor and the
wanting to play with the
the idea that humor covers humor
covering pain
was um something that i realized i was
really familiar with in my own life
not not the same pain that she's
carrying but just kind of
letting things be funny before there's a
hat and um
and then realizing that was something i
wanted to play with and then building a
dramatic story
into that but um but at the heart of her
yeah like that sense of always feeling
like you've got to be
on your a-game and be in control of
everything and know and know the answer
to everything and
i don't know the answer to all your
problems before anybody else does kind
of
you know that she's like i've got this
i'm totally on top of this i'm not sure
i have to know the game
like if you're putting humor first and
you're sort of you feel like you have to
be on top of everything everything
becomes kind of a game and that's how
you can be on top of it you know yeah
i know the better insult here you know i
know i know the way to
to jibe everybody a little bit more yeah
and being able to say like i don't
really
like a cab i don't really care you know
and that's constantly all the way
through it and then
hopefully there are moments that she
lets slip that you realize my god she
really does care and she's
um in like relationship with her sister
as well i have a sister i'm very close
to and a brother as well and that whole
relationship of
kind of sparring siblings who are
completely different
but totally devoted to each other and
can be so horribly cruel as well as
kind to each other i think the depth of
knowledge of a character
is definitely when you write it yourself
is undeniable um but really when i first
wrote her
i was writing all the things that felt
sort of dangerous to say
and um and i knew that i could only
really
give that to myself didn't want to give
that to anyone else
in case it bombed and then it would be
like that was that bitch's fault
not mine um so i think it was partly
that but also i had this like
i felt when i was you know i was in my
mid to late 20s when i first wrote the
play
and it came out of a need to play
someone who was
complex and weird and had these multiple
layers and had
and had a persona and then had somebody
truthful underneath and had all that
complexity
but it was also was funny and dark and
sort of sexually candid all of those
things were things i desperately wanted
to play as an
actor anyway um so that's kind of where
it where it was born out of and i had
had those experiences before
my first ever ever play that i performed
in was a play called crazy love by jay
walker
and he had just written this really
angry posh
bride and but i love that she was angry
because you know posh brides are like
you know
they're all over the place um but but an
angry one
and one that had you know had had
secrets and that was the first time i'd
really felt like
oh there's something else i can play and
i'd felt the pressure coming out of
drama school to basically be a sort of
princess um either like a sexy princess
or not sexy princess that was like the
two
things and like and in one way or
another she's a princess you know no
matter what the story is
um and so i wanted to play someone who
was a kind of a darker version of that
and then going on i mean i do
disassociate slightly when i'm writing
um because i want to shock myself and
surprise myself when i'm writing it
and sometimes you know write things and
be like i don't want to
say that but those are the moments that
you know
are feel dangerous and feel truthful and
i think
that was it's actually a good challenge
to to make me
want to play it as well as you know
write it hi phoebe
uh i just want to say i found the
character very relatable
and you know she lost a partner and uh
you know her family doesn't understand
her
and you know she's just trying to make a
human connection yeah um but
but the lead is that okay sorry we're no
we're here we're here for you
but but the lead on on her character is
that she's
unlikable like why do you think that's
the lead on on the character i guess
like if it was a man would it be
celebrated
her qualities i guess yeah i don't think
it would be it would
that would be the sort of tagline of the
of the reviews and the press if it was
um
if it was a man i think it's
i mean i i don't find her unlikable at
all and i was worried you know i was
worried
that if people didn't see her pain
underneath it all
and that her her
attitude was just kind of dismissive and
she just you know
didn't seem to care like she that's
clearly what she's trying to make you
think but if
we were too convincing and she just
didn't care and she was just being
a dick then i think that would justify
that but i think
we were careful to build in as much
humanity as possible so
it just kind of surprises me when people
say unlikeable maybe not unlovable i
don't know
also you can't help if people don't like
you it would kind of still work if the
humanity wasn't there and it was like an
episodic
show you would have a kind of seinfeld
or always sunny type of character and
you can just sort of
apply them into any situation and watch
them kind of squirm around it
but because you applied this humanity it
makes her extremely likable i'm not
really sure yeah i think it's the kind
of unrelenting smugness that she has
at keeping you on side which i think can
probably rub people up the wrong way if
they don't if they're not sensitive to
the fact that it's clearly a
an act i was captivated by this
character who
said all the things that we think but
dare not admit to and i realized as i
was watching it that i
i am fleabag there's a little bit of
feedback in everyone
and that there's a little bit of
everyone in fleabag darling i am flee
back
everyone can relate to fleabag man woman
and child
hey
[Applause]
she comes out into the world fighting
she wants to be funny she wants to
entertain you she wants you to have a
good time
but also she desperately wants to
connect and i feel like
we can all relate to that to a certain
degree but she's still
outrageous and horny and busy
and tired you know like the rest of us
what advice do you have for actors who
want to start writing for the first time
um
to kind of start creating their own work
in the way that you have
[Music]
well i mean do it for a start
um even if you're even if you discover
that you don't enjoy doing it or if
you're not if you don't feel like you're
good at it or if it doesn't go down well
if you're just not good at it
but i think just try it because there's
something about writing
that is um
you learn so much about character from
writing and i know a lot of actors that
like will write themselves letters from
their characters and things like that
before they actually
perform and i've never been that kind of
actor but but i think it's because
because i want to write as well but i
can see that thing once you're actually
writing things down and writing dialogue
down you learn
so much more than than even in real life
you know if you write yourself a kind of
if you just
dare yourself to write something
truthful that you think and it feels
kind of dangerous because
it's like writing a diary that you know
no one's going to look in
and that's kind of what it felt like
with feedback i just thought i'm just
going to write what
will make vicky laugh was the first
thing and would make vicky feel
seen and make vicky uh and having that
one person in my head was really helpful
but
the advice i think is right write as if
you're not afraid
um and the same goes for acting act like
you're not afraid
just or if you weren't allowed if like
if someone just said there's no
there's there's there's no reason to be
afraid here just go for it and that was
the line that i i constantly say to
myself when i'm writing and acting
how did you get involved with amazon how
did it end up working out that way so
they um the bbc saw the play in
edinburgh and asked for a pilot
and then um we were given about 10
pounds
to make the pilot and um
exactly one month without a free trial
and then um and because it was one of
their like this bbc three kind of comedy
feed thing that they call it and uh
but because we managed to pull in an
amazing
uh like crew and dop and and director
and everything because
they were just hanging around in london
for those couple of weeks and
um and they liked the script so in the
end the pilot which is the first episode
just looked amazing for the um for the
budget that we had because this amazing
team
and then um but we knew that if we
wanted to keep that level
we'd actually have to like pay them
properly and um so
my producers went to amazon and said
look because they loved the pilot but
they said we can't make it at this level
like we wanted
um anamorphic lenses and stuff which
apparently are all really expensive
and um and they're like we need some
amazon came on board and kind of
get for the episodes two to six and uh
just really loved it and just gave us
match the budget to help us make the
show we wanted to make
and it was so great because they were
just like we love it go and make it
you know without kind of being too
overbearing they were just really
sort of creative friendly it was lovely
having
written both comedy and drama which
do you find uh easier or more enjoyable
and if for the rest of your life you
could only do one or the other which
would you choose
oh no i don't think i could because i
think they're so intrinsically linked
i feel like if there's comedy
if people are laughing they're kind of
giving you their heart a bit so
they're sort of asking you to break it
in some way i think because
i don't know i just feel like they're
they're
they're too closely entwined i found it
so during com when i was writing fleabag
and crashing i was like i just want to
write
drama i hate this like on having to do a
tick thing on the page of like there's
like six jokes on this page and
having to be about generating material
and jokes was exhausting but
now i'm writing a drama i'm like i just
want to put a joke and everything's like
like how do i know if it works
where's the humanity i think finding the
humanity and drama for me is
has been an interesting journey because
i think
people being funny or jokes reveal so
much so quickly about a character
but people staring meaningfully down a
corridor
and then walking with absolutely no
sense of humor to go and sign a form
i'm like like what's fun about that but
then but it's important so i
i don't um i don't know there is there's
a lot of humor in the drama that i'm
writing so
um i don't know i think i just have to
kill you if you made that
you